el águila ha aterrizado fueron las
palabras que eligió el ministro de salud
australiano al anunciar la llegada al
país del primer lote de vacunas más de
142.000 dosis del fármaco desarrollado
por facer han llegado al aeropuerto de
sídney
y eso significa que vamos a liberar
después de que todos esos procesos se
hayan completado rosemary
entonces aproximadamente 80 mil dosis
para las primeras vacunas que comenzarán
en australia el lunes 22 de febrero y se
kent el cb los trabajadores de la salud
y personal de asistencia a personas de
la tercera edad estarán entre los
primeros en ser vacunados australia de
25 millones de habitantes se vio
obligado a imponer un nuevo
confinamiento en melbourne para contener
la circulación de la variante británica
en nueva zelanda también llegaron este
lunes las primeras 60.000 dosis de facer
en el caso del país vecino la estrategia
es de empezar con los trabajadores de
las fronteras a partir del sábado todas
las garantías de control de calidad
tienen que ser completadas antes de que
las vacunas sean enviadas
en oakland la presencia de la variante
en tres miembros de una familia llevó a
casi dos millones de residentes a un
confinamiento de tres días desde el
domingo beneficiados por su remota e
insular ubicación geográfica australia
con menos de mil muertes y nueva zelanda
con apenas 25 hacen parte de los países
que mejor han manejado la pandemia